hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the Potter
family godric's Hol Voldemort and
October 31st
1981 specifically we're going to be
tackling the question of why James posa
didn't act as his own Secret Keeper
instead entrusting the responsibility
with known rat Peter pettigru join me as
we dive deep into the fidelia's charm
and the role of The Secret Keeper in the
tragic events that led to the downfall
of James and Lily Potter let's get
started we all know how devastating it
was when the Potters were killed leaving
baby Harry as the only Survivor it was a
defining moment in the story of the boy
who lived and many fans have debated the
events that led to their untimely deaths
to understand what happened we need to
take a closer look at the fidelia charm
this powerful spell is used to keep
secrets hidden and secure and it relies
on the presence of an individual known
as a Secret Keeper but what happens when
the Secret Keeper is not the best choice
what if choosing differently could have
saved lives to answer these questions we
first need to properly grasp what the
fidelus charm is and what being a Secret
Keeper really means imagine a spell so
powerful it can hide the location of an
object or person from prying eyes that's
the Fidel charm this ancient and complex
enchantment is one of the most
formidable defensive spells in The
Wizarding World the Fidel's charm works
by confining The Secret in this instance
the location of the Potter Cottage
within the sole of a designated Secret
Keeper Only The Secret Keeper possesses
the knowledge of the Hidden location
while all others remain completely
unaware think of it as an invisible
magical lock guarding the secret with an
unbreakable Bond but but as powerful as
the fidelus charm is its effects are
useless without a reliable Secret Keeper
selecting the right Secret Keeper is no
easy task and the task becomes even more
crucial when life and death are at stake
it requires absolute trust and loyalty
as the person chosen holds the key to
the hidden secret the identity of the
Secret Keeper is known only to the
person who cast the charm and the Secret
Keeper themselves The Potter's decision
now let's Dive Into the Heart of the
matter why did James Potter choose Peter
pettigru as his secret keeper instead of
being his own it's a question that has
haunted fans for years let me start by
addressing the first part of the
question why Peter lifelong friends
James Sirius Remis and Peter the
Marauders were tight-knit and their
friendship ran deep they shared
Adventures mischief and secrets during
their time at Hogwarts forming an
unbreakable Bond James and Peter were
lifelong friends and they really didn't
have any reason not to trust Peter a
diversionary tactic for those unaware
James Potter actually initially chose
Sirius Black as his secret keeper in
fact Sirius was the man who most
believed to be the Potter's Secret
Keeper however Sirius thinking that
Voldemort might Target him suggested
that they choose pettigru instead the
following excerpt from Sirius addresses
this Lilian James only made you Secret
Keeper because I suggested it I thought
it was the perfect plan Voldemort would
be sure to come after me would never
dreamed they'd use a weak talentless
thing like you it must have been the
finest moment of your miserable life
telling Voldemort you could hand him The
Potters by selecting Peter the seemingly
least likely candidate they hoped to
throw off the scent unforeseen betrayal
after being made Secret Keeper it didn't
take Peter pigr long to reveal his true
colors in one Infamous Act of cowardice
and disloyalty revealing the location of
the Potter Cottage to Voldemort Peter
was no friend of James but instead a
cowardly death heater sympathizer who
went wherever he believed the power to
be Peter's cowardice inevitably cost
James and Lily Potter their lives
effectively orphaning the boy who live
alternative secret Keepers provided that
the downfall of The Potters was almost
exclusively due to their choice of
Secret Keeper I can't help but ask
myself what if someone else was chosen
and who better to leave the secret with
than the Potter family themselves would
James have survived if he had chosen
himself as The Secret Keeper what if he
conjured up the courage to trust in his
own ability to protect his family the
first thing I'll mention is that there's
a fair bit of ambiguity with regards to
who's actually qualified to be a secret
keeper in the Deathly Hallows it's
revealed that bill Weasley is the secret
keeper for Shell Cottage and Arthur
Weasley is the secret keeper for the
burrow given that these are their places
of resid residence it proves I think
that a person who lives in the house
being protected can also be eligible to
be its Secret Keeper by this logic James
poser would have been a suitable
candidate to be the secret keeper for
their Cottage in godric's Hollow one
possible reason why James may have opted
not to assume the role of Secret Keeper
for his own home could be due to the
fact that he himself needed to remain
hidden from potential threats it's
speculated that the Fidelis charm makes
the dwelling untraceable through such as
owls and petronis communication and in
this regard Arthur and Bill Weasley had
the advantage of potterat to stay on top
of ever changing events in The Wizarding
World this resource was not available
during the first war meaning that if
James were to serve as his own secret
keeper and go into hiding The Potters
would not only be untraceable but also
entirely disconnected from The Wizarding
World alternatively James could have
chosen to appoint himself as Secret
Keeper and disclose the secret to a
trust Confidant who would act as the
intermediary between the potters and the
Order of the Phoenix Sirius would be the
obvious choice here however if something
were to happen to him the poter would
once again meet the risk of separation
from wisting society it's also worth
pointing out that there is a bit of a
difference between the way Bill and
Arthur used the charm versus James's
potential use in the case of shell
Cottage and the burrow the Fidelis charm
protected the property and its occupants
by extension however in the unique case
of the Potters the purpose of the
fidelus charm cast upon them was
slightly different its main objective
was to safeguard the Family itself
rather than placing emphasis on their
humble Cottage this Revelation is
discussed by Professor Flitwick in the
prisoner of aaban as he imparts wisdom
on the inner workings of the fidelus
charm as long as the Secret Keeper
refused to speak you know who could
search the village where lilan James was
staying for years never find them not
even if he had his nose pressed against
their sitting room window the intention
behind casting the Fidelis charm upon
the Potter's Cottage in godric's Hollow
seems to have been focused on concealing
the family rather than solely isolating
the property this could be attributed to
the fact that the Potters had no need or
desire to come into contact with
individuals outside their trusted circle
on the other hand the Weasley being
active members of the order required
interaction with fellow members leading
them to protect only the locations of
their homes under the charm what's also
Al worth mentioning is that no one truly
knows if hiding one's own person via the
Fidel's charm is even possible while
James Potter may have technically been
eligible to serve as the secret keeper
for the cottage the ambiguity
surrounding with the charm protected the
property or the Family itself coupled
with the obscurity surrounding the
implications of the latter leaves it all
a bit too wide open why not Dumbledore
while we're on the topic I think the
elephant in the room needs to be
addressed why not Dumbledore why not
select the most powerful wizard of all
time who's also your major Ally to hold
your secret for you dumbledor to me
seems like an obvious choice as Secret
Keeper he wouldn't have even needed to
be secretive about it Dumbledore's
high-profile but it wouldn't have
mattered Voldemort himself feared
Dumbledore so the prospect of him being
taken down or targeted for information
was extremely unlikely Voldemort's fear
of Dumbledore is even referenced by
mcgonagal but you're different everyone
knows you're the only one you know all
right Voldemort was frightened of in the
prison of asaman it's even revealed that
Dumbledore offered to take on the
responsibility James poter told
Dumbledore that black would die rather
than tell where they were that black was
planning to go into hiding himself and
yet Dumbledore remained worried I
remember him offering to be the Potter's
Secret Keeper himself this means that
even though Dumbledore offered James
Potter's blind trust in Sirus Black and
his friends whom he deeply trusted was
his eventual downfall
Dumbledore was close with James but he
wasn't one of the Marauders and I guess
James felt that he could only trust his
friends to the extent required I think
that one of the main reasons for James
not selecting Dumbledore is that
Dumbledore had recently formed a
relationship with the defecting Death
Eater sever Snape Snape came to
Dumbledore when he learned that Harry
and the Potters were the target of
Voldemort's attack which presumably
prompted the use of the fidelus charm in
the first place this means that by this
point dumble had accepted that Snape had
switched sides however his new
relationship with Snape may have
instilled doubt in his other allies
allies like James Potter ultimately they
decided to go with someone that they
were completely familiar with and
unfortunately their misjudgment of Peter
petr's character was their ultimate
downfall my closing thought on this
matter is that it really could have been
avoided they could have chosen almost
any other Secret Keeper and things would
have turned out fine furthermore it was
a strange decision to hide the Potters
in such plain sight a big house in
godrick Hollow seems like a strange
place for a family being hunted down by
vort himself and that's it for this
video what do you think had this thought
ever occurred to you please let me know
down in the comment section below until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to
live